nos piden dividir 30.24 entre punto 42 y
los invito a qué pausa en el vídeo y
traten de resolverlo por su cuenta antes
de ver cómo lo resuelvo aquí hay dos
formas de pensar en esto una es
escribirlo como 0.42 / 30.24 pero ahora
qué hacemos aquí lo importante es darse
cuenta que cuando tenemos una división
de este estilo tendremos el mismo
resultado siempre y cuando multiplicamos
y dividamos ambas cantidades por el
mismo número
podemos reescribir esta división como
30.24 entre 0.42 estos dos son iguales
estoy expresando lo mismo de estas tres
maneras y esto no va a cambiar su valor
cuando lo multiplicó y lo divido por la
misma cantidad qué cantidad debe
multiplicar al denominador para que
quede como entero
bueno lo voy a multiplicar por 10 y por
10 es decir por 100
lo multiplicó por 100 y para no cambiar
el valor de todo esto el numerador
también lo debo de multiplicar por 100 y
esto sirve entre 100 es lo mismo que un
entero lo estoy multiplicando por 1 así
que no le cambia el valor por lo que nos
va a quedar que esto es igual a 3000 24
entre 42 en esta forma lo que hacemos es
recorrer el punto decimal dos lugares de
aquí acá está el punto y de aquí acá
ahora aquí está el punto y ahora sí
podemos hacer la división tomando en
cuenta que nuestro punto va a estar aquí
muy bien vamos a realizar la división
directamente de hecho la voy a
reescribir para que quede un poquito más
claro sin tanta línea nos queda 42 entre
3 mil 24 y bueno esta es una parte para
encontrar qué números de aquí tengo que
considerar para multiplicar con el 42
o que estos dos primeros números este 30
es menor que el 42 por lo que no me
sirve tengo que tener un número mayor a
42 aquí dentro de la división así que
voy a tomar el 302 bueno qué números
multiplicado por 42 se acerca a casi 300
vamos a ver 7 por 4 28 vamos a probar
con el 7 7 por 2 14 7 por 4 28 y una que
llevamos es 29 hacemos la resta
ok aquí necesito 12 porque 2 es menor
que 4 no lo puedo restar entonces aquí
tomo prestado un 9 y aquí me queda un 12
12 menos 4 es 8 ahora de aquí no puedo
tomar este 9 porque realmente no es un 9
este lugar de hacer un 0 yo tuve que
pedirle prestado al 311 para que esté 0
se volviera un 10 y a ese 10 quitarle un
1 de manera que me queda el 9 para que
este 2 fuera un 12 y ahora hago me
restan 9 menos 90 2 menos 20 me queda 8
ahora bajo este 4 y bueno creo que aquí
lo pueden ver bastante evidente que no
me lo ha multiplicado por 42 mil 84 pues
va a ser 22 por 2 42 por 48 84 menos 84
es 0 es una división exacta
esto es igual a 72
esta división es la misma que ésta por
lo que esté 30.24 en 3.42 es igual
también a 72 y con esto terminamos este
ejercicio